louis burton participera une nouvelle
fois la transat jacques vabre le skipper
originaire de rambouillet sera départ de
cette 15e édition avec son bureau vallée
3 le navigator aura pour objectif de
terminer dans le top 5 de cette course
transatlantique qui reliera le havre à
la martinique on a le bateau pour cette
année on aura quand même pu naviguer pas
mal avec on a nos sponsors et donc dur
vallée en tête qui nous permettent de
faire un nouveau jeu de voiles qui nous
permettent de vraiment préparé notre
bateau donc on vise un top 5 et on rêve
on rêve secrètement de monter sur le
podium mois pour sa sixième
participation louis burton partir avec
son ami de longue date davy beaudart un
skipper qui devrait lui permettre de
remplir ses objectifs on est déjà parti
ensemble avec des vues en 2019 c'est un
ami ça c'est sûr depuis très longtemps
mais c'est aussi un grand champion
puisqu'il a il a gagné énormément
énormément de courses dans toute sa
carrière et puis c'est quelqu'un qui a
une grande compétence dans le
développement technique des bateaux et
est donc on est assez complémentaires
sur ces aspects là et ça se passe très
bien sur l'eau on se complète avant la
course et sur l'eau on fait tout
ensemble le départ de la transat jacques
vabre est programmée le 7 novembre
prochain à 13h30 direction à les
antilles pour la flotte